تقع مدينه فلوريس في الريفيرا الفرنسيه
المطله على البحر المتوسط مدينه عرفت منذ
نح سبعه عقود بكونها عاصمه فن صناعه الخزف
والفخار في
فرنسا قصد الكثير من الفنانين فوريس لانها
تزخر بالمعارف والخبرات في مجال الخزف
وبالتاكيد لكونها مصدر
الهام فن صناعه الخزف يحمل طبعا خاصا لدى
بيكاسو انه عمل بسيط يمارس بواسطه الطين
لكنه مهم بالنسبه اليه كلود ايو هو احد
اقدم الحرافيين في المدينه استقر عندما
كان صغيرا في فلوريس قادما من ايطاليا مع
والده الخزاف ومن ثم بدا يتعلم تقنيات
تشكيل
الصلصال انها عمليه
التدوير يستغرق تعلمها كثيرا من الوقت
لانها تقنيه
يدويه وتتطلب براعه
واتقان وهي المرحله التي يبرز فيها الحس
الابداعي
ح ذاتها تضاهي اللمسه
السحريه كنا نستعمل من قبل عجلات تعمل
بالساق اما الان فنستخدم دواليب كهربائيه
ما عدا ذلك حافظنا على الاسلوب نفسه بعد
تجفيفها خلال عده ايام يتم شوي القطع
المصقوله بالنار داخل الفرن وهي مرحله في
غايه
الدقه يشوى هذا الخزف طوال ع ساعات على
الاقل تحت حراره 14 درجه مئويه احيانا
تحدث مفاجات غير
ساره اثر ذلك تطل اوعيه الفخار بالمينا ثم
تشوى من جديد اذ تستلزم بعض الاعمال
الخزفيه الحديثه عده اسابيع من العمل
الدؤوب تستغرق القطعه الواحده وقتا طويلا
اي حوالي 15 يوما
تعود تقاليد صناعه الفخار في فوريس الى
العصور القديمه فمنذ العصر الغالي
الروماني يصنع سكان هنا اواني طبخ من
فخار كانت فوريس تتمتع بكل المقومات
الضروريه لصناعه الفخار اعني بذلك وفره
التربه الطينيه والمياه والغاب ستعمال
الخشب في عمليه
الشو في الاصل كان الخزف يستخدم لابتكار
اواني الطبخ مثل المقلاه وشتى انواع
القدور
الخزفيه وكانت تطل في السابق حتى تحافظ
على تماسكها ويمنع التسرب عند طهوي
الطعام كانت عائله ماس رائده في تاريخ
صناعه الخزف في فوريس مع نهايه القرن
التاس استطاعت ان تخرجها من النمط
التقليدي الى النمط
الفني لقد ابتكروا اشكالا فنيه تطلع عاده
بماده ملمعه وهي نتاج عمليه كيميائيه
دقيقه تعتمد على الشو كما يمكن تزيينها
بالذهب او الفضه او النحاس
ايضا عائله ماس زودت بابتكارها الكثير من
العائلات الملكيه الاوروبيه التي ترتاد
الريفي الفرنسيه خاصه بعد ما وصلت الحدي
الى سواحل المتوسط كانت تمتلك هذه
العائلات منازل كبيره وفاخره وكان من
الضروري تزيينها
بالمزهرية
التي انشات هذه الورشه عام 38 ومن ثم
انطلقت مغامره فنيه استثنائيه بما ان
بيكاسو صنع في هذه الورشه ما بين 3000
و4000 قطعه فريده من
نوعها بخوضه مغامره فنيه جديده كان بيكاسو
يختبر مهاراته في فن صناعه الخزف الذي كان
يعتبره مصدر الهام فني لا
ينضب هذه القطعه هي احدى اروع الاعمال
الخزفيه الت ابدعها بيكاسو انها الطائر
الكبير وهي تحفه استثنائيه تختلف عن باقي
اعماله الخزفيه وبما ان بيكاسو كان يسعى
الى نشر اعماله تم استنساخ بعض اعماله
المميزه في الورشه طبقا للنسخه الاصليه
فهذه التحفه اعيد تصميمها في 25 نسخه
ونلاحظ من الناحيه الاماميه صوره الوجه
المستوحى من احد اعمال الرسام مايكل
انجلو طاب المقام لبيكاسو في مدينه
وبقي فيها طوال سبع
سنوات كان بيكاسو متوسطي وواجد في فلوريس
نورا ليس غريبا عنه ومجتمعا كدحا يعرفه
وكانت سعادته الكبرى تكمن في عيشه حياه
طبيعيه بين اناس بسطاء يعتبرونه عبقريا
انه نمط جديد في الحياه مختلف عن الحياه
الباريسيه المضنيه المدينه عاشت ببيكا سو
وبروح الفنان حتى ان وجوده في فلوريس قلب
حياه اهلها على
عقب